أرسل ريتشارد روث ، آخر موظف أصلي متبقٍ في شبكة CNN في سبتمبر / أيلول
، رسالة إلى زملائه
في العمل ، حيث كان في حاجة ماسة إلى
كلية جديدة ، وأوضح أنه على
الرغم من حصوله على عملية
زرع كلية منذ 25 عامًا ، إلا أنه يموت الآن
بداخله.  وذلك عندما ردت
زميلته نائبة مدير التحرير
لوحدة تحقيقات CNN ، سميرة جعفري ،
على المكالمة التي بدأوا فيها
اختبارًا مكثفًا لتحديد ما إذا كانت تتطابق مع
عيد الشكر ، ثم أصبت
بقشعريرة يوم الثلاثاء ، لقد نجح ريتشارد في
الحصول على كلية من الكلية.
المرأة التي يسميها الآن بطلتته
وكلاهما معنا الآن إنه لأمر
رائع أن
أراكم كلاكما آه أريد أن أسألكما نفس
السؤال ريتشارد يبدأ معكما
كيف تشعرين جسديًا
وعاطفيًا
مؤلمًا قليلاً بشكل مفهوم
مع الشق وهذه الأوقات الخطرة
لأن لدي القليل جدًا من
التثبيط المناعي ضد أي عدوى
أو مرض.
بعد هذه المقابلة مع جامعة
ييل نيو هيفن ميديكال حيث
أجريت الجراحة لأول
فحص لي وكذلك سميرة
أنا محظوظة جدًا
في مضمار السباق
الذي أحببته ولكن أه حتى الآن مع
شريان الحياة الطبي هذا  أن سميرة أعطتني أه
إنه صاعد وما فوق ،
إنه لأمر رائع أن أسمع أنه من
الأفضل أن تكون محظوظًا بهذا الأمر أكثر من أن تكون محظوظًا في
حلبة السباق أه سميرة كيف تشعر
أنني أشعر حقًا أنني أشعر بالرضا ،
فأنا أصبح أقوى كل يوم
كريتشارد  ذكرت
أنني أيضًا لدي موعد للمتابعة
اليوم ، وآمل في الواقع أن يتم السماح لي
بالسفر للعودة إلى المنزل إلى أتلانتا
أوم ، لكن الجراحة كانت بالتأكيد
أسهل على جسدي منها
في ريتشارد ، لذا فأنا أتجذر باستمرار
بالنسبة له وآمل أن يشرب كل
يوم
أيضًا سأقول إنكما تبدو وصوت رائعًا ،
حسنًا ، أعلم أنك
تمر كثيرًا ، خاصة أنك
ريتشارد الآن ،
أريد أن أحكي قصة كيف
جاء كل هذا  أن تكون بسبب سميرة cnn
و t  إنه شيء عندما يأتي
الناس للعمل في CNN سيقولون أنه أمر كبير ،
لذا من الواضح أنكما وريتشارد
تعرفان بعضكما البعض أنكما لم تعملا
عن كثب لم تكن لديكما علاقة
حيث كنتما زملاء مباشرين ،
فكيف فعلت هذا  كل شيء يأتي ليكون
آه لا ، هذا صحيح ، أنا نوع من
المزاح أن كليتي التقت بريتشارد قبل
أن أفعل ذلك شخصيًا ،
لكنني كنت قد عملت فقط مع ريتشارد
ريتشارد عبر الهاتف الذي قمت بتحريره في
وظيفتي القديمة بعضًا من  نصوصه ، لكنني في
الحقيقة كنت
أتجاهل بريده الإلكتروني ، لقد
تأثرت به وعرفت أنه كان
أصليًا في شبكة CNN ، كما أنني كنت
معجبًا جدًا بما فعله
كصحفي ومن كان وما زال
كذلك  شعر الإنسان وكأنه
شيء يمكن أن أفعله في تلك المرحلة من
حياتي ، لقد شعرت أنه من الممكن بالنسبة لي
أن أفعل ذلك ، لقد عرفت أه فقط
في المستوى الأساسي ، كنت أعلم أن هذه
العمليات
الجراحية ناجحة ولكن
الصعوبة الحقيقية غالبًا  ناجح ولكن
الصعوبات الحقيقية في الواقع  العثور على
المتبرعين ، لذلك شعرت وكأنني كنت
في مكان ما في حياتي ربما يمكنني
رفع يدي والبدء به
، وربما أكون المباراة
التي
تتطلب شجاعة هائلة بالإضافة إلى اللطف
ريتشارد ، كيف تشكر شخصًا
أنقذك؟  الحياة
كنت أتساءل عن أن
سميرة ليست من النوع الذي
يبدو أنه
يتلقى الربت على ظهره
والمجد هي ليست من هذا النوع من الأشخاص
أه لذا ربما يكون الخروج
بالفكرة الصحيحة أصعب قليلاً  لكنني
سأخرج بشيء أه أنت تعرف أنني محظوظ جدًا ، أعني أن
هناك 117000 شخص
يبحثون عن الكلى والكبد
والعديد من الناس يموتون كل يوم
أعتقد أنه يمكنني فقط أن أسأل
أشخاصًا مثل سميرة أو
يميلون إلى النحافة  بهذه الطريقة للتفكير في
التبرع لصديق أو قريب ،
كانت سميرة خارج المستشفى في اليوم التالي ،
لكن لولا قائدنا السابق
جيف زوكر
كرر مناشدتي في المكالمة الجماعية الصباحية على CNN ،
فربما تتمكن سميرة من المشاركة
فيما حدث  ثم كيف قريبة
كان لسماعها عني ، من
فضلك ، ما كنت سأقرأ
البريد الإلكتروني ، كنت سأستقبل مئات الرسائل الإلكترونية التي
لم أكن قد قرأتها ، ولا
أه لا شيء عن ريتشارد ، أنتم يا
رفاق تعرفون عدد رسائل البريد الإلكتروني التي نتلقاها  يوم واحد
وهو مجرد أم ومقدار
الحركة حول هذه الشركة أه
كم من الأخبار تنتقل وإذا
لم يقل جيف ، أحتاج يا رفاق لقراءة
البريد الإلكتروني لريتشارد روس ، ربما كنت
سأفتقده في المخطط الكبير لـ  أشياء
وأنا سعيد حقًا
لأنني لم
أفعل ذلك ، وأم ريتشارد أه هو لا يحتاج إلى فعل
أي شيء آخر لم يُظهر ريتشارد شيئًا
سوى الامتنان والشجاعة خلال هذه
العملية برمتها ، أريد حقًا أن
يتم صنع الكثير منها  أنا وأنا فقط
نريد حقًا أن يفهم الناس أن
الأمر الحقيقي لن يكون ممكنًا
بدون جراحينا لدينا جراحين رائعين
كنا في أيدٍ رائعة وفي
كل مرة أفكر فيهم
وأريد تسميتهم دكتور
هوكينسون ودكتور كولكارني في  مركز زرع ييل
أسفل للتو  كان الشارع مني
كان فريقهم مذهلاً وفي اللحظة التي
التقيت فيها بهم أدركت أن هذا ممكن تمامًا
ليس فقط بالنسبة لي ولكن بالنسبة لكثير من
الناس ، لذا يجب الإشادة بهم حقًا
في هذه العملية ، نعم هناك
الكثير من الأبطال الذين
سأفعل ذلك  باختصار ، أشكر جميع
الأشخاص الذين حاولوا مساعدتي على
طول الطريق وأشخاص CNN السابقين
وأنا غارق في رسائل البريد الإلكتروني
والتغريدات الأشخاص
الذين يسألونني عادةً هل ما زلت
تعمل والآن من الأفضل أن تبدأ كيف
تشعر ،
نعم هذا  هذه أخبار جيدة لريتشارد ، هل يمكنك
إخبارنا قليلاً عن
كيفية اكتشافك أن سميرة كانت
على استعداد للمساعدة في ما كان عليه مثل
مقدار الوقت بين إرسال هذا
البريد الإلكتروني بدافع اليأس
ومعرفة أنك ربما ستحصل
بعض
المساعدة أحتاج إلى إعادة النظر في هذا لأنني كما
يعلم الجميع ، أقوم بحفظ كل بريد إلكتروني تقريبًا
وأعتقد أنه كان بريدًا إلكترونيًا وليس مكالمة هاتفية ،
لكنني بالتأكيد أريد التحقق مرة أخرى ،
أعلم أنني قمت بحفظ واحدة أو اثنتين من رسائلها الهاتفية
أنا  يعني أنه كان من الممكن أن تترك الدراسة في أي
وقت كان لدي شخص أو شخصان يفعلون ذلك ،
وكان لدينا أطباء يستبعدون
بعض الأشخاص الآخرين الذين قلتهم دائمًا
لأشهر حتى تصبح هذه الكلية بداخلي ،
فأنا لا أملك الأمل لأن هذا
أمر محفوف بالمخاطر.  هل
أه ريتشارد أعتقد أنك
اشتهرت في هذه الشركة
بحس الفكاهة لديك وأيضًا
بدفئك ولطفك ومن الجميل جدًا
أن ترى أنك تعود إليك يا سميرة
أنت بطل الجراحون هم أبطال وهي
فقط جميلة  للتحدث إليكم
اليوم ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم وأتمنى لكم التوفيق
في كل من تعافيكم